δεν απόφαση σας δεν νομίζω να την περίμενε κανένας για να είμαι ηλικρινείδι ότι δεν
την μοιράστηκα και με κανένα θεωρώ ότι ξέρετε μας αρέσει να θεωρούμε του σε αυτούς
μας ότι δεν είμαστε εμείς εκεί δεν μπορεί κανένας αλλος να κάνει αυτό που κάνουμε
δεν είναι έτσι και εγώη ίδη και με τον λπίζω και με σίγουρι ότι θα
θα πετύχει στην ακρόαση του κινοβουλίου με τον κύριον κάτημα μόλις ανακλοινώθηκε το όνομα του
τον πύρο τηλέφωνο έχουμε μιλήσει έχουμε συναντηθεί το στηρίζω όταν μου ζητά όπως μπορώ αλλώς
εκεί μας υχαριστώ πάρα πολύ λίγ νσυνέδευξη όπως είπαμε ίστενανα τομε το οποίο δεν υπάρχει
κανείς να πηνκαδι αρνετικό με πλούσιον έργο και σίγουρα η χώρα μας μόνο ότι χερή
πρειανιώθει που επειστρέφεται πίσω γιατί διάνούμε και μια περίοδο όπου υπολιτική ζωή του τόπου δενείναι
και στα καλύτερα ίσα μου επιτρέπε να το ποέτσι και χρειάζεται άτομα όπω ε σας
κυνα κυρ για τ κί χαριστώ πάρα πολύ για αυτή τη στέσε πολύ χρειαζόμαστε και
ο κόσμος χρειάζεται να να έχει μια καθαρό πολιτικό λόγο και να νιώθει ότι αυτό
που βλέπει απέναντι του ατό είναι να σας ευχαριστήσω γι αυτή την ευκαιρία και να
σας ευχαριστήσω και για τενηδιαίτεροτόνο βουδόσατε με ένα ρόθματιλάκη δραηο μου μήνυμα γιαλάτε γι' αυτό
τομήματ δεν πέρασε παρα τη αριστο πόλι υχαριστηκαλά φιλές και φίλει άλλο ναντν άλλα επποτκασεεφτασε
στο τέλος του να ευχαριστήσουμε και τα αν πιν πάρε που μας κράτησαν παρέα τα
λέμε την ερχόμενη ευδομάδα με την κυρία φολινή υπαπαδοπλα